once upon a time.
A text to image AI art generator was tasked with creating a
humanoid robot.
Reading the wall street Journal sitting on a yellow bench.
Actually there were lots of different kinds of robots who liked to sit and
read the paper,
but only one of these robots is actually real.
Well a real human under a real robot suit your
real right?
I am real.
The rest of these robots were created by artificial intelligence
using text to image generators.
But how do they work with new tools like open a eyes dolly to and stability eyes.
Dream Studio you can type in a phrase and outcomes an image
nothing in these generated images you're looking at right now is copied and pasted from
google images or some photo agency.
But how does the quality compare to real photos?
We came up with a challenge to test the limits of ai photo generation and to see
if it can compete with humans or in our case a real
photographer and a real man named Peter caucus.
I lined up everything with his real elaborate and handmade
robot suit which takes an hour to put on.
What does this mean about telling real from fake on the internet.
I'm gonna explain it all with the help of this guy.
I don't think he's actually gonna be that much help.
Let's start with how this works.
Both dolly too and Dream Studio provide a simple text
box.
You say whatever comes to mind say a photo of a robot in the forest with a
balloon.
Then both systems take a few seconds to generate some pretty accurate and
funny images.
You might think,
oh the system is just looking at images of robots and balloons and putting them together
but no in the background your text is sent to open
ai or stability ai where their powerful artificial intelligence has learned to make
sense of that text and translated into completely original images.
How did it learn?
What is what?
By looking at billions of labeled images.
Think of it like flashcards,
the Ai sees those all and starts to learn that many sci fi robots have eyes and
boxy heads and a square stomach.
Same with balloons.
It learned that most balloons are this shape and have strings on them and it even has this little tie
thing through deep learning it not only knows that that's a robot and that's a
balloon but it knows the relationship between two distinct objects.
So it automatically puts the balloon in the robot's hand.
Just like I knew to put the balloon in his hand on the shoe
or at least dolly knew to put the balloon in a hand.
Dream Studio was pretty confused by the whole robot balloon thing.
Creating basic images.
Is just the start of what you can do with these tools.
If I wanted to take a Polaroid of this real robot sitting by the pool drinking a beer.
I need to get an instant camera and a beer Wall Street
Journal and a beer.
Yeah this is gonna be the keeper or I could just type in a
humanoid robot sitting by the pool drinking beer taken with a Polaroid camera.
The systems understand different art and photography styles so you can do things like fixing
the office printer in the style of a medieval painting or an Andy Warhol
style painting of a bunny rabbit wearing sunglasses,
realistic photographs are definitely one of the hardest challenges for these systems.
Take a high quality photograph of a robot walking a cava poo.
Our photos turned out great dolly on the other hand,
had an idea of what a cava poo looked like,
but the rest was.
Yeah.
And I have no idea what's going on here with dream studios creation.
Now here is one of the coolest tricks peter.
Can you put your hand in like this for me?
Okay then I can take this shot uploaded to dolly and to add in whatever I'd like
in this area with a feature called in painting and then you can
export all those stills and make something like this.
So in real life or even in an ai generated image.
These scenes are pretty fun.
A robot doing some everyday things.
But what if you wanted to make something not as fun.
Maybe something gruesome or based on a real life event or a real life public
figure.
Say joe biden eating a cupcake,
open a eyes,
dolly will immediately restrict searches like that as the company prevents searches with names of
public figures and various hateful or harmful words,
searches for other names do work like this is what it thinks of
Joanna Stern in space.
When I put that joe biden prompt into Dream Studio,
it generated this image stability.
A eyes founder Ahmad must stock said he saw no reason to restrict the ability to
generate images of public figures.
Now say you try a photograph of a terrorist attack.
Dolly didn't generate any really believable images but it did conduct the search.
Dream Studio generated clearer images with guns and fire.
If you look closely,
you can see issues with the quality.
But let's face it,
people don't always look so closely on social media.
This all leads to the bigger tech question,
how are we going to be able to tell the difference between the real or the fake or the Ai
generated images on the internet.
Open a eyes policies encourage users to indicate that content is a I generated.
It also places this watermark in the bottom right of every image,
but it can easily be cropped out stability.
AI doesn't require any crediting right now.
Another way to tell the real from the fake is quality.
It depends on what you need a realistic photo.
Well,
you're still probably gonna need a photographer and props like we had today.
I don't need any help but quick,
compelling graphics and illustrations for a presentation website or more.
This would do the trick And Microsoft is even incorporating dolly into its new
designer app and being image creator website.
Bottom line AI art tools are getting real good,
real fast.
But you're a I generated robots won't be able to explain the art behind
their creation the armor
plated butt cheeks.